so where we had left off Benjamin
Franklin had had pretty much established
himself as a successful printer and like
its content producer writer if you will
media mogul media mogul in Philadelphia
were in the 1730's we're trying to
answer kind of the late seventeen 30s
now at what point does he make the
transition from I guess media mogul to
to statesman or leader which starts off
when he was just a young assistant
printer when he was only 21 he starts a
little Club sort of a civic club almost
like a rotary or Kiwanis Club for
middle-class tradesman and artisans and
this shopkeepers of Philadelphia he
calls it the leather apron club
sometimes known as the junto leather
apron club because it was not for the
rich elite you were you know the famous
business owners nor for the poor working
men it was the people put on leather
aprons every morning and opened up a
shop and stood there behind the counter
and that leather apron Club is becomes
the foundation as he becomes a
successful businessman for all of his
civic endeavors he was sort of a the
club trained people in a way to be civic
leaders they made a list of the virtues
you needed to have to be a good civic
leader such as industry and honesty and
frugality and Franklin was so geeky he
put it on a chart and every week he
would mark how well he did on each of
those virtues and at one point he had
mastered all twelve of the virtues he
showed it to the other people in the
leather apron Club and one of them said
hey Franklin you're missing a virtue you
might want to try Franklin says what's
that and the friend says humility you
might want to try that one for a change
Franklin said I was never very good at
the virtue of humility but I was good at
the pretense of it I can fake it very
well and here's the important thing by
it Franklin he says there's what he
writes he says I learned that the
pretense of humility was just as useful
as a reality of it because it made you
listen to the person next to you try to
find the common ground and that was the
essence of the middle-class democracy we
were trying to create that's a and so
how does I guess how does describe me
into I mean I'm sure they're meeting
they're making lists of yeah sort of
every Friday they
meet and besides making trades they make
a list of things that can improve the
community and so they come up with plans
there is the first library the first
sort of lending library of Philadelphia
I think that was like in 1731 he does a
lending library that's even before the
first poor Richard so that was the first
thing they do because he believed that
the young tradesman you know the rich
people had their own private libraries
but that there should be a free library
one that people could borrow the books
then they do a street sweeping Corps and
they do a militia they do an Academy for
the education of youth that becomes a
University of Pennsylvania they do an
insurance company for widows and orphans
and you know his mother is somewhat
baffled because she's an old-fashioned
Puritan and says you can only get to
heaven through God's grace alone not
through good works and Franklin says
well I'd rather have it said of me that
he lived usefully than that he died rich
and I believe that the best way to be in
favor of the good Lord is to do things
for all of his fellow creatures that he
created and so that was Franklin's credo
which is let's do good civic works they
create a hospital even in order to help
our fellow man because that's what the
good Lord wanted us to do passe